no sadly how vulnerable people in care
homes are to cope at 19 what is the
situation on the front line hello good
morning I think he is very very
challenging and having been clearly
identified as the biggest risk group we
were suddenly forgotten about really in
the planning and I think there's been a
very reactive approach so we've got
members who are really struggling with
with the with the PPE they're struggling
with making sure that they're keeping
their staff protected as well as the
residents of course but but we'd
starting very early on we started to
realize that we were going to see that
really challenging sickness rate where
people are self isolating and the whole
thing kind of exploded very very quickly
but providers were very responsible very
early on and started to shut down the
services to open visiting although they
are still enabling people to come in
where the need arises and I think what
what we're challenged with is that
despite a number of promises and a
number of announcements that have been
made for example the 1.6 billion that
was given for Social Care a lot of
providers they have no idea where that
is they're not being they haven't even
got the notification of annual increases
for the services so so my members are on
averaging about 550 pounds a week and on
that which is less than four pounds an
hour and on that they are trying to
manage this pandemic without much
support coming from anywhere and I think
that's the challenge are our members are
facing at this moment in time and all
providers it's interesting to hear you
say that you feel that care homes were
initially forgotten about because right
up to the 13th of March their care homes
were being told by the government that
it remains very unlikely that people
receiving care in a care home or the
community will become infected do you
think that we were just very slow to
realize just
what the crisis in care homes could be
yeah and I think that you know that's
what it was reactive it it's never been
proactive because a lot of it could have
been avoided if the testing had been in
place very very quickly and we we
thought about all those things and the
PPE wasn't being diverted just to the
NHS so our own suppliers were telling us
they couldn't supply us with the PPE
because it was all been gathered to the
NHS leaving the care home sector
completely exposed so so I think it's
been reactive very very slow coming and
even now although the announcements have
been made about testing what we're now
being told is that somebody with a home
in Norfolk is being told their nearest
nearest test centre is Sheffield well
you know there's no planning don't make
announcements unless we know what the
plan is behind it because it doesn't
actually help or support us as providers
it doesn't create confidence in our
staff who are working that this
brilliant team of staff out there who
have been doing this job undervalued
year on year for decades is suddenly now
in the front line and we're trying our
upmost to try and keep them safe I'm
interested to know a bit as well about
whether you think that the kind of
official statistics on care homes and
matching the reality of what is
happening inside our care homes the
daily death figures of course only
include those people who have died after
testing positive in hospital for cope at
19 Matt Hancock said on Thursday only 15
percent of care homes have seen
outbreaks do you think that sounds right
well I think is very difficult because
I've seen the numbers that are being
talked about an hour until testing is
done we don't know I have an uncle who's
currently he's got cancer and you know
he's at an end-of-life care so we there
are expected deaths that that will occur
in services but without testing without
actually at the very beginning starting
to look at the statistical evidence it's
very difficult to say
where we are with the number of debts
and actually you know care homes
generally have always been a very
supportive environment for all providers
it's a home for all residents it's a
home from home and there are a lot of
people in these services and the
families out there with who are watching
all of this unfold and they'll be
feeling very very very worried so we
need to be we need to be responsible
about how we reflect this and of course
there will be deaths though that I'm not
denying that they're artists and the
numbers we won't be able to confirm
until and unless the data's analyzed
understood and a quick thought for me
because we are running out of time but I
did want to get your opinion on the
badge that Matt Hancock announced
earlier a badge of honor for carers is
that a good move or is it a little bit I
don't know that's rising well I think
it's a symbol and if people like the
fact that it's a symbol then that's good
I'm more interested in the tangible been
the the tangible support that they can
give us and I think we need the money
that local authorities are being given
coming being passport it through to us
more than then I need to focus on a
badge